fans have been waiting years to find out
which new twists would be added to the
story by the new creative team for the
rebooted Hellboy franchise
we're gritting our teeth dusting off our
tomes of BPRD history and casting a
spell of blood magic to bring you all
the small details you missed in the 2019
version of Hellboy Hellboy starts the
movie heading to Mexico to find a
missing BPRD
agent and close friend Esteban he finds
his old pal wrestling in a Lucha Libre
arena under the name commas odds
seemingly indifferent to hell boys
concern in the comic storyline Hellboy
in Mexico Hellboy teams up with a group
of 1950s luchador ace while fighting
vampires in Mexico after a night of
heavy drinking one of the brothers
Estevan wanders out into the night and
gets turned into a vampiric luchador
called kama Zots the movie closely
follows the storyline as Hellboy is
forced to battle against the giant bat
creature impaling him on a ring post the
movie even includes the months-long
drinking vendor that Hellboy goes on
afterwards when Hellboy gets picked up
by BPRD agents in Mexico professor broom
lets him know he has to go to the Osiris
Club to help them out with a giant
problem that they're having when he
shall called Society one in 1866 by the
ranking members of the Helio Pat
Brotherhood of Iran in the comics the
healy effect Brotherhood is a group of
supernatural obsessed cultists who went
around causing trouble
they usually battled against Sir Edward
grey the Witchfinder of Victorian era
precursor to latter-day heroes like
lobster Johnson and Hellboy the
Brotherhood's referenced in the film
isn't just to show that the new film is
firmly and meshed within the larger
Hellboy comics universe it's also a sly
bit of foreshadowing to the Osiris
club's betrayal of Hellboy while on the
wild hunt if you got a phobia of eye
trauma
stay away from this movie Hellboy
himself blinds at least three different
monsters on screen
plus there's Baba Yaga the witch who
lost one eye to Hellboy before the
movies events she's eager to pop alona
Big Reds yellow eyes into her socket she
offers Hellboy a deal for information on
Nimue way the Blood Queens next move and
return for one of his eyes Hellboy
accepts but ends up reneging on the
telling the witch that she can have the
eye when he's done with it that might
not have been the right decision he gets
hit with a nasty curse and ends up
losing out on some knowledge the Hellboy
probably should have remembered the
Norse myth of Odin who is said to have
traded an eye for divine wisdom Hellboy
is able to get out of the trade with
baba Yaga by telling the witch that she
never specified a time frame to collect
his eye
it's a savvy trick that gives our hero a
high ground for not staying true to his
word when making a deal with a child
killing cannibal witch and it also
subtly connects Hellboy to Nimue a a
significant portion of the film is
devoted to Hellboy struggling with his
duel loyalties to humanity epitomized by
professor broom and monster dumb
represented by Nimue a she tells him
that they're bound by fate that might be
true but they're also bound by how
tricky they both are after GRU 'gosh
defeats Hellboy in combat
Nimue a takes the former's power away
when gruha got to reminds Nimue a that
she promised to make him whole she
responds that she did she just didn't
tell him for how long Nimr way and he'll
boys duel trickery connects the two
characters when Hellboy leaves her house
with both his eyes baba yaga curses him
that he'll use both of his eyes to see
the one person he loves most in the
world suffer and die later in the film
alice is hit by one of Nimue as
poisonous needles and her outlook seems
grim with alice knocking on heaven's
door it seems like the film is setting
her up to be the unfortunate recipient
of Baba Yaga's curse but all she needed
was a little Merlin magic to get back up
on her feet the curses real target seems
to be professor broom who animu a kills
while Hellboy watches the wild hunt is
another element of the movie straight
out of European myths there are many
many variations of the myth but one of
the most consistent aspects of the hunt
is that it presages an outbreak of war
or plague the wild hunt of Hellboy is a
bit distinct in that everyone involved
in the hunt
except for Hellboy is a normal human
Nimue is known for bringing with her
plagues and destruction and there are
definitely enough demons and soldiers
milling about in the final scenes to
qualify as a war one of the most
memorable lines is when Hellboy rebuffs
Nimue a's offer of romantic alliance by
telling her that
you know just I'm a Capricorn and it's
not actually accurate though in the
comics Hellboy's given birthday is
October 5th which would make him a Libra
it's easy to see why screenwriter Andrew
Cosby went with the Capricorn the zodiac
symbol is a goat Hellboy's demon father
takes the form of a goat occasionally
and Hellboy's horns are goat like one of
the Huntsman asks Hellboy what his rocky
right hand is used for the smashes
things real good that lion might have
come as a shock to superfans at the
comics in 2004's Hellboy since they know
that hell boys right hand of doom is the
key to controlling the augur jihad
Lovecraftian creatures from beyond space
and time none of that place into 29
teams Hellboy largely because his space
worm controlling stone hand isn't part
of the movies doomsday prophecies it's
more of a battle between his demonic
evil and Arthurian good twin Heritage's
with the forces of evil kept decidedly
in the folklore and hellish realms while
Hellboy's appearance on a small Scottish
island after a Nazi ritual is kept
fairly faithful to the original comics
there is one noticeable twist in the
original comic the torch of Liberty a
creation of John Burns that was loaned
to Mike Mineola on a one-time basis is
there since the character figured so
prominently in Hellboy's origin you'd
expect him to make another appearance
but due to copyright issues Vignola has
steered away from ever reusing the torch
in the movie the Pope hero who is there
is lobster Johnson
whenever Mineola and his collaborators
needed to use a pulp hero to fight Nazis
in the Hellboy Universe
they used the lobster making him an
official witness the Hellboy's arrival
on earth is a pretty declarative
statement that the film takes place
within that larger universe more
importantly they kept his catchphrase
beware my claw for I've come to inflict
justice the filmmakers are clearly
trying to reboot the Hellboy franchise
with this movie and they wanted to avoid
audiences confusing it for a sequel so a
lot of familiar faces from the previous
films don't appear yet if the ending of
the film is any indication they knew
that they could only get in one movie
without Hellboy's good friend Abe Sapien
herb played by Doug Jones and Hellboy
and Hellboy 2 the Golden Army Abe Sapien
is an excuse appian a more humanoid
creature from the Black Lagoon the
closing scene of 2019 s Hellboy features
Hellboy Alice and Ben de mio raiding a
warehouse in Siberia with a tank that
reads eek Theo sapien if the film ends
up earning a sequel it's a sure bet Abe
will appear Hellboy's post-credit scene
finds the half-demon getting
prodigiously drunk at his father's grave
only to be interrupted by the lobsters
ghost
Hellboy geeks out at meeting his
childhood hero and the lobster gives a
stirring pep talk to get Hellboy back on
his feet if there's one thing Hellboy
loves doing it's getting drunk with
ghosts boy I need some ID bailiff are
you sure in fact that's how the wild
hunt storyline in the comics starts
Hellboy is called to lead the hunt after
going on a boozy tour of Great Britain's
finest ghost houses some character beets
are simply too important for any
adaptation to ignore check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about superhero
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell see you
don't miss a single one